mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour vous le savez c'est la grande
nouvelle de cette matinée un homme de 42
ans monsieur beaux lots a été arrêté
cette nuit par les gendarmes de sainte
maxime mathieu boulo et professeur de
psychosociologie à l'institut de
formation pour adultes de boulogne
billancourt et monsieur bolo passer ses
vacances en compagnie de sa femme au
domaine de la nartelle près de 5 maxi
monsieur borloo a été inculpé ce matin
officiellement par le juge d'instruction
de draguignan monsieur huot marchand d'
incendies volontaires et il a été déféré
ce matin incarcéré à la prison de
draguignan donc en fin de matinée
monsieur vau l'eau et donc semble-t-il à
l'origine d'une bonne partie des
incendies qui ravagent depuis maintenant
48 heures cette région de la côte d'azur
la région de saintes max et avant de
passer la parole à jean karl heinz qui
nous attend en ce moment à marseille
je voudrais vous donner un petit chiffre
un chiffre encore inexactes bien sûr
mais qui va vous donner une idée quand
même assez juste de l'étendue des dégâts
depuis 48 heures que ce soit sur la côte
d'azur en provence voire même encore
plus de 20 mille hectares de pinède et
de forêts ont été la proie des flammes
et sont donc complètement détruit c'est
dire qu'en 48 heures le feu a ravagé a
fait presque autant de dégâts que
pendant toute l'année dernier alors jean
pierre lannes
il doit nous attendons qu'un marseille
je vous demande pardon le téléphone bien
jean pierre lannes pas encore prêt sans
doute un film de dernière minute à
monter je vous le disais donc cet homme
a été arrêté cette nuit par les
gendarmes de saint tropez et c'est la
grande information de la journée jean
kerlann nous expliquera tout à l'heure
comment ça s'est passé comment s'est
passé cette nuit lui même était sur
place toute la nuit il a suivi bien sûr
avec les gendarmes
une reconstitution assez dramatique et
il a suivi bien sûr aussi les efforts
des pompiers des sauveteurs qui essayait
bien sûr d'enrayer ce fut donc si vous
voulez nous y reviendrons tout à l'heure
dès que nous en la liaison avec mass
et puis si vous voulez aussi le point de
la situation c'est un poil la situation
dans le var en fin de matinée ce point
la situation le voit ce mise à part la
zone du plan de la tour où il ya encore
cinq points d'un standing ou encore
maîtrisé les sauveteurs tiennent la
maîtrise du feu dans l'ensemble du
département du var et cette dépêche nous
indique que tous les feux sont
circonscrits
et seule une surveillance est exercé
vous le voyez donc une situation qui
évolue pour l'instant favorable à
l'étranger c'est la grande bretagne qui
retient aujourd'hui l'attention des
observateurs
d'une part avec la grève des 47 milles
dockers qui préoccupe bien sûr le
gouvernement de monsieur x
mais nous allons y revenir dans un
instant et puis aussi par une rencontre
politique d'importance qui aura lieu
soit en fin de matinée soit au début de
l'après midi en train de monsieur x est
le premier ministre d'irlande du nord
monsieur les deux hommes vont évoquer
bien sûr le retrait possible des soldats
britanniques qui sont stationnés en
irlande du nord
et puis aussi ils vont dresser le bilan
de ces manifestations orangistes de la
semaine dernière des manifestations qui
auront lieu à nouveau manifestation
orangistes qui auront lieu à nouveau le
12 mai je voulais dit en commençant
c'est sans doute sans nul doute bien sûr
la grève des dockers une grève qui
paralyse 47000 dockers qui préoccupe le
plus ce monsieur is le point de la
situation maintenant avec stéphane paul
c'est la première fois depuis 1926
qu'une grève générale illimitée des
dockers a lieu en grande bretagne ce
mouvement qui menaçait depuis plusieurs
jours a été rendu effectif après que les
délégués des 47 milles dockers eut
rejeté mercredi les dernières
propositions des employeurs ainsi que
l'amendement du syndicat des transports
qui proposait d'ajourner la grève durant
la poursuite des négociations situation
grave donc en grande bretagne d'autant
que l'économie britannique s'appuie en
grande partie sur l'exportation pour
pallier à cette grève le gouvernement de
monsieur issa pris un certain nombre de
décisions sur les box et la troupe
britannique qui assure le chargement et
le déchargement des cargos c'est là
l'une des conséquences de l'état
d'urgence qui a été décrété hier sur la
totalité du territoire
la décision prise dans l'après midi par
le gouvernement a été aussitôt ratifiée
par le conseil privé réunis sous la
présidence de la reine elizabeth rentrer
quelques heures plus tôt de sa visite au
canada
l'état d'urgence avait été décrété la
dernière fois en mai 1966 par le
gouvernement travailliste de monsieur
wilson lors de la grève des gens de mer
l'un des éléments qui avait conduite à
la dévaluation de la livre
stéphane bohli vous le disais cette
grève a souligné une fois de plus la
dépendance de la grande bretagne pour
ses plus approvisionnement
approvisionnement qui se font à
l'extérieur et paradoxalement c'est au
moment
où les ports britanniques sont paralysés
par cette grève et interdisent tout
moyen de communications avec l'extérieur
que l'on reparle d'un projet le projet
du tunnel sous la manche avec nous sur
ce plateau d'information première
monsieur jacques de vos goûts et qui est
le secrétaire général du groupement
d'étude pour le tunnel sous la manche
alors monsieur de vos goûts il ya une
question que l'on peut se poser bien sûr
tout de suite ce projet tunnel sous la
manche n'est pas un projet nouveau
il date de quelle année très exactement
vers 18 110 c'est la première fois qu'on
en a parlé sous napoléon et depuis il ya
eu d interruption très longue est
véritablement le dossier a été rouvert
il ya 13 ans en 1957 au moment où le
groupement d'étude du tunnel sous la
manche a décidé de procéder à une étude
complète du projet bien lors le groupe
dont vous avez la responsabilité a
déposé il ya quelques temps ces
conclusions quelles sont-elles sait plus
exactement ce groupe a fusionné avec
deux autres groupes financiers
internationaux
or mettre ensemble des propositions au
goût à l'étude des gouvernements et une
décision sera donc prise incessamment
une décision doit être prise dans les
temps le restaurant reste de l'année on
peux pas vous dire exactement à quelle
date parce que c'est il faut que les
services ministériels étudie encore
lorient on peut dire que l'on est rentré
donc dans une phase active dans ce
projet de construction de tunnel sous la
manche je crois qu'on peut le dire
normalement maintenant les principes on
est d'accord sur les principes de part
et d'autre et on devrait pouvoir aller
vers une réalisation alors nous allons
proposer maintenant aux téléspectateurs
un petit film qui a été tourné par nos
camarades britanniques et qui va montrer
peut-être si vous voulez l'état non pas
des travaux mais l'état des projets où
en est on de part et d'autre de la
manche
voilà alors ça je crois que c'est faux
lequel stone c'est l'entrée britannique
de ce tunnel sous la manche c'est exact
c'est le ce sont les travaux qui ont été
en 1880 à peu près du côté anglais les
mêmes travaux ayant été fait du côté
français il ya une plaque d'ailleurs qui
marque justement cette date de 1880 et
ce sont de vieilles galerie ce sont de
vieilles galerie qui ont très très bien
résisté au temps puisque quand on est
quand on y retourne et on a trouvé que
laroche n'avait pratiquement pas bougé
alors cette roche bien sûr a donné lieu
à des noeuds
analyse nous les voyons en ce moment à
des recherches quelles sont les
conclusions qui ont été faites par tous
les savants tous les techniciens qui se
sont penchés sur cette étude géologique
du terrain et bien les conclusions c'est
qu'on se trouve heureusement en présence
d'une couche que monsieur louis armand
appelait le paradis des géologues
car c'est une couche de calcaire
suffisamment contact compact et
suffisamment entendre en même temps pour
qu'on puisse opérer par machine poreuse
et non pas par explosifs ce qui donne
une rapidité beaucoup plus grande à
l'avancement voilà deuxième point
maintenant les maquettes qui sont mises
à l'étude
ça c'est une maquette anglaise maquette
anglais certainement d'une gare routière
de deux fins de terminus du terminal du
tunnel ceci d'ailleurs depuis on a fait
quelques progrès dans l'étude dès
maintenant le chargement des voitures
sur les navettes s'opérerait d'une façon
beaucoup plus simple sans ces mouvements
de 2,2 qu'est qu'on voit la mer alors
une question
voilà certainement l'image que l'on aura
dans quelques années un train qui rentre
dans un tunnel
et puis à la sortie soit l'angleterre
soit la france selon le point de départ
que l'on a pris ce tunnel sous la manche
effectivement on pourra l'emprunter donc
dans combien de temps
sans faire preuve d' optimisme excessif
je pense qu'on peut dire que vers 1978
les travaux pourront être achevés ya dix
ans la reine 1970 une idée du coût de
l'opération le coup se situerait aux
environs de quatre milliards de francs
mais avec un financement très largement
répartie d'abord entre la france et la
grande bretagne est également sur le
marché d euros de ville pour toute la
partie empreintes du projet monsieur de
vos goûts vous remercie marseille est en
ligne paraît-il heures jean pierre
lannes
si vous m'entendez est ce que vous
entendez jean pierre lannes bien oui
jean pierre comment en est on arrivé à
cette à cette arrestation de monsieur
bolo cette nuit vous avez suivi les
événements toute la nuit est ce que vous
pourriez nous refaire un petit peu tout
le parcours tout ce cheminement pour
arriver à l'arrestation de monsieur
boulot oui la nuit dernière il était à
peu près 10 ont 22 heures nous
apprenions qu'un témoin à ce moment là
un témoin important était entendu à la
gendarmerie
de sainte-maxime des témoins aurait
soupçonné piste et puis conduit au poste
cet homme monsieur bolo donc qui rôdait
dans le domaine privé de la nartelle la
nartelle se situe à la sortie de 5 de
maxime sur la route de saint raphaël et
nous reviendrons si vous voulez ce soir
plus longuement sur ce témoignage est
sûre ce rôle joué un rôle très important
joué par les témoins mais revenons donc
au déroulement quasiment de cette nuit
4h45 tout d'abord le procureur de la
république qui était venue spécialement
de draguignan sort du poste de
gendarmerie
derrière lui le juge chargé de la faire
et enfin celui qui n'était jusque-là
4h45 que le témoin numéro un et je donne
je donne ces précisions
parce que les phrases et des images qui
vont suivre une non exclusion d'ailleurs
sont un peu confuses un peu sont en
effet les quelques journalistes présents
attendaient ce moment depuis plus de six
heures et nous étions donc tous plus ou
moins fatigués en tout cas cela se
passait donc je répète à 13h45 dans la
cour de la gendarmerie tout d'abord le
produit mis qu'un break pour l'instant
il y as reconstitution d'un gâteau vous
confrontation monsieur le juge nous
allons sur les lieux j'en ai lu avec le
témoin numéro un avec tous les témoins
et qu'est ce que vous allez faire de ce
témoin après la reconstitution nous sont
dans quelques-uns peut-être je n'ai pas
l'habitude de prendre une décision avant
d'avoir vu jeudi les deux solutions ont
été avancées par les missions locales en
une seule question est est ce que le
pays qu'il soit après la reconstitution
maintenant dans une heure ou deux a mené
dans une maison d'arrêt y trouve qu'il
est inculpé
c'est une question à laquelle je crois
une frappe a répondu monsieur il est
inculpé pour l'instant et sa femme est
libre
inculpés d'incendié volontaire la
décision devait banderas de l'accusation
dit volontaire monsieur le juge est
depuis quelques heures maintenant
ici même donc pendant cette longue étude
qui a duré six heures aux athlètes
donc il va partir la maison d'arrêt de
riom tout à l'heure non il est inculpé
je lui ai notifié une inculpation
maintenant je lui notifier une
inculpation gens suivent la halle pour
l'instant là derrière le g maintenant
vous allez le voir
l'inculpé puisque il est inculpé
monsieur bolo déclaration à faire
je voulais passer une nuit blanche les
musulmans toutes les accusations qui
sont portées contre eux tout cas
pourquoi j'aurais écrit avait tellement
dantesques et l'extraordinaire séquelles
et vous vous y sentez il est 5 heures du
matin vous êtes totalement détendu je
n'ai pas l'impression de ce qui se passe
autour de vidéos j'ai l'impression que
je prends votre femme qu'il était donc
cinq heures et nous avons pu suivre
policier témoin juge et accusés et au
petit matin se déroulait alors l'ultime
confrontation sur le terrain les témoins
tout d'abord charles
à l'intérieur la parole la plus simple
voilà paris je levais par là dans ses
environs non je le voyais davantage un
peu plus à droite ici et sa femme
étaient derrière voilà les témoins sont
au nombre de cinq
trois hommes et deux femmes étaient
partis en direction
l'accusé se défend écoutez bien
alors qu'il est là a confié ce rôle elle
il va alors oui j'ai tâché nuit là je la
lui mme jeux mac ou pis je me relève je
l'éteins j'aimais jouer avec les
allumettes et je vais en allumer un
autre un peu plus loin il ya une
question que j'aurais quand même posé
qui est très importante cette notion de
responsabilité vous êtes un des témoins
à charge principaux et imaginez un
instant que cet homme ne soit pas
coupable maintenant lajux donc se
défendre pied à pied et cet incendie là
que nous voyons et devant cette maison
devant sa maison
pourquoi yoann english mais comme il l'a
dit lui-même il n'est pas tout à fait
normal c'est lui même qui l'a reconnu je
suppose que c'est une des raisons
principales c'est une telle
responsabilité quand même a votre avis
il faut faciliter mais si on a une
certitude la responsabilité encore plus
grande de ne pas témoigner
voilà donc affaire à suivre et je vous
donne rendez vous à ce soir je pense que
nous reparlerons
voilà un père qui tarde maintenant
peut-être sur le plan des incendies bien
sûr et bien il y a deux bonnes nouvelles
le vent ne s'est pas levé et
pratiquement maintenant tous les choyer
sont solidement maintenu par les
pompiers merci jean pierre lannes donc
rendez vous tout à l'heure à 19h45 vous
l'avez vu une nuit et une matinée très
mouvementée reprenons le fil de ce
journal avec si vous le voulez bien le
reste de l'actualité internationale
en bref le président nasser a regagné
l'égypte aujourd'hui après un voyage de
dix neuf jours en urss et un communiqué
soviéto égyptien sera publié cette nuit
communiqué qui fera le bilan de cette
visite du président nasser un must au
cambodge
la situation militaire reste pont fut
cependant les troupes cambodgiennes ont
repris hier vous le voyez sur cette
carte
la ville de kiri rome à 90 km au
sud-ouest de phnom penh qui rit rome
souvenez vous c'était l'ancienne
résidence de vacances du prince norodom
sienne
et puis sur le plan diplomatique il faut
signaler aujourd'hui la visite au
cambodge dans un lieu encore inconnu du
président de la république sud
vietnamienne le général dit en argentine
les autorités argentines les autorités
de buenos aires ont annoncé aujourd'hui
que le corps de l'ancien président de la
république argentine le général
hambourg ou enlevé le 29 mai dernier
avait été retrouvé enterré dans le
sous-sol d'une ferme à timothée une
petite localité située à 500 km environ
de buenos aires
un suspense qui se termine après bientôt
deux mois de recherche en italie reggio
de calabre connu pour la troisième nuit
consécutive des violences les
manifestants qui entendaient protester
contre le choix de la ville de catanzaro
comme capitale régionale de la calabre
se sont affrontés assez violemment vous
le voyez aux forces de l'ordre
milan 20 blessés et 30 arrestations
enfin à washington accueil très
chaleureux pour le prince charles et la
princesse anne d'angleterre que vous
voyez sur cette photographie en
compagnie du président et de madame
richard knicks restent aux états unis
mais nous allons tout à fait changer de
sujet vous allez le voir puisque le
téléphone télévisé c'est tout du moins
le nom que l'on lui donne vient d'entrer
en service entre new york et
philadelphie et c'est françois cluzet
qui a eu le plaisir pour vous de
composer le premier numéro d'appel le
téléphone télévision le pitch faune
vient d'entrer en service entre new york
et philadelphie plier sont encore
expérimental mais qui ouvrent une ère
nouvelle dans les télécommunications
techniquement ce mariage du téléphone et
de la télévision paraît assez simple à
réaliser
en pratique l'installation d'un
véritable réseau se heurte à des
difficultés considérables
le nouvel appareil est un peu plus
délicat à manier que le téléphone
la caméra de télévision et en plus
compliqué que le micro les américains
semblent bien imprudent dans les
applications qu'ils envisagent shopping
et papotages à domicile s'il commence
par là il est satureront leur réseau
avant même de l'avoir construit non les
communications d'affaires auront sans
doute et pendant longtemps la priorité
étant donné le coût relativement élevé
de telles installations
toujours dans le domaine scientifique et
technique voici maintenant des petites
nouvelles des cinq femmes aquanautes qui
vivent au large des îles vierges dans la
mer des caraïbes à quelque 15 m de
profondeur et vous voyez en ce moment la
maison sous la mer leur maison sous la
mer par est il doté du plus grand
confort et pourquoi pas d'un téléphone
télévisée hier soir sur la piste de
melun villaroche la société aérospatiale
française a présenté à la presse son
dernier-né le biréacteur corvette et
c'est michel polacco qui assistait pour
nous à cet essai en à 17h30 une petite
éclaircie a permis à corvette de prendre
son premier envol corvette
le dernier né de l'aérospatiale un
biréacteur issu d'une collaboration
étroite dès 1967 entre nord et sud
aviation
il a été conçu après la mise au point
des réacteurs larzac à double flux dont
il est équipé et qui en sont le
principal est tout ça 1700 kg 750 km
heure huit à treize passagers 2000 km de
rayon d'action une grande maniabilité
corvette semble avoir séduit ses pilotes
de ces bancs et 40 l'après-midi d'aller
se promener loyers très vite on a dû
faire une pointe aux alentours de 320 à
l'air et on s'est limitée à 900 mètres
d'altitude
étant donné que la couche était complète
c'est difficile d'une opinion appareils
un vol mais enfin nous sommes très
surpris fait surpris par la facilité du
vol pas surpris par le silence du vol et
nous avions un peu l'impression de faire
un vol de tourisme
quand vas tu semble donc un avion au
point il s'agit maintenant d'assurer son
avenir le petit biréacteur restera très
rentable en raison de son prix
d'exploitation qui est comparable à
celui des avions à turbopropulseur
fermant ses performances d'autre part en
font un avion qui a un marché double de
celui de ces pseudo concurrents
notamment parce qu'il peut utiliser tous
les aérodromes avec ou sans piste dure
comme le confirme l'ingénieur chargé de
sa mise au point
c'est un avion qui peut utiliser des
terrains cours et donc apporter les
liaisons rapides de l'avion à réaction
sur des quantités d'aérodrome qui lui
était jusque là inaccessibles enfin et
surtout c'est dans sa catégorie le plus
économique et grâce surtout aux
réacteurs à double flux qui consomment
beaucoup moins de carburant que les
autres et qui sont nouveaux et lorsqu'il
sera commercialisé dans deux ans et demi
est ce qu'il sera toujours la pointe du
progrès on met certainement parce que
les avantages que présente ne seront pas
concurrencé par d'autres qui présente
des caractéristiques très différentes
les sports à présent michel drucker de
l'athlétisme à stuttgart oui hier soir à
stuttgart le match d'athlétisme
allemagne etats unis s'est terminée par
un nouveau succès des athlètes
américains 122 à 100 ce qui représente à
un point après les quarts qui sanctionna
le récent match d'athlétisme france
etats unis parmi et les victoires
allemandes citons celle de noor porte
sur 5000 m 13 minutes 34 secondes 6/10
nord potes il s'avère quand même
d'europe de la spécialité
au 3000 m steeples victoire de birth by
de 8 37 2 le sens hauteur a été remporté
par mme aguer lavesque de mettre 17 ce
qui constitue un nouveau record
d'allemagne au lancement du marteau ou
vbr a réussi 70 mètre soixante dix huit
beyer et vous le savez depuis déjà
longtemps un des meilleurs lanceurs du
monde
mais l'épreuve la plus palpitante a été
indiscutablement le 800 m que nous
allons revivre maintenant avec un habit
loin à 800 mètres qui a enthousiasmé les
cent mille spectateurs du stade de sugar
oui michel ce fut un 800 m royal 1 800
mètres comme on n'en avait pas vu depuis
la mémorable finale olympiques de mexico
avec masques royal du bel et le kenyan
épreuve but au départ de la corde à
l'extérieur l'américain vinton reid 20
ans
qui porte des lunettes à ses côtés
l'allemand quimper maillot blanc aux
commandes d'europe en huit minutes 44
secondes neuf dixièmes puis ken benson
21 ans maillot sombre révélation de
l'année et enfin adams quatrième dans la
finale du 800 m des jeux de mexico
voilà le départ est donné pour une
course de rêve une course à suivre qui
peut lancer sur un rythme élevé par
l'américain vince henrie à la corde il
va prendre immédiatement la direction
des opérations
comme vous allez le voir le duel
implacable entre les américains les
allemands et dès maintenant entamer
binzème reid est en tête suivi de
l'allemand adam svensson qui sera le
héros de la course est troisième
kemper quatrième cela va vite très vite
même
vivendi prend tous les risques il sait
qu'il est vulnérable dans les 50
derniers mètres mais il va servir à son
camarade svensson une savoureuse
victoire
cinquante et une seconde 6 pour 400 m
marc ville d'ennery continue son
cavalier seul sur la même note
allègre d'étudiants de l'université de
wisconsin sans accélérer encore dans le
virage
regardez bien qu'un père à droite il ne
peut suivre le rythme endiablé
d'américains il décroche progressivement
la phase la plus émouvante de la course
se déroule maintenant sous nos yeux
keynes benson l'étudiant de l'université
du kansas s'est placé derrière dins énne
reid
cela va vite toujours très vite svensson
maintenant attac a lancé la ligne droite
sens qu'il est souple mais nerveux adams
portant a dû l'ouverture à l'accord dit
laisser s'infiltrer
la victoire semble tout à coup à sa
portée mais wentzel passe maintenant et
ils n'emportent en minutes 44 secondes
8/10 4e performance mondiale de tous les
temps adam sessegon en une minute 44
secondes neuf records d'europe et galets
kemper troisième une minute 45 secondes
4 vince enrique quatrième une minute 45
secondes six
nous revivons au ralenti cette dernière
est magistrat ligne droite où tout s'est
joué sur le thème d'un vibrant suspense
l'attak incisive d'adams à la corde le
retour inattendu de cannes père la
lumineuse fin de course de svensson qui
triomphe keynes benson
retenez ce nom il appartient désormais à
la lignée des plus grands du demi fond
mondial
sohn nouvelle étoile nouvelle vedette de
l'athlétisme mondial il était d'ailleurs
à paris récemment puisqu'il avait
remporté le 800 m du match france etats
unis les athlètes américains vont se
rendre maintenant en union soviétique
pour rencontrer les russes ce match
union soviétique états unis aura lieu la
semaine prochaine à leningrad ce sera
très certainement le sommet de la saison
d'athlétisme à kelis toujours à colombes
dix buts ce soir débute ce soir les
championnats de france
et pendant trois jours les 600 meilleurs
athlètes français vont s'affronter au
cours de quatorze heures de compétition
la télévision en direct sera présente
demain et après demain au stade de
toiles on le tour de france il faut bien
en parler nous approchons de la fin
c'est aujourd'hui la 21e étape ruffec
tour 191km merckx et les autres traverse
quatre départements la charente la
vienne l'indre et l'indre-et-loire
l'arrivée à tour est prévue vers 16h30
vous suivrez bien sur les derniers
kilomètres en direct notre information
sportive en bref une information triste
mort du rugbyman andré bonneau le trois
quarts aile de toulon andré bonneau a
succombé la nuit dernière à toulon c'est
une dépêche de 12h48
il a succombé à une hémorragie cérébrale
et est âgé de 24 ans andré bonneau avait
remporté avec son club au mois de mai
vous en souvenez très certainement le
challenge yves du manoir il avait été
champion de france du 100 m automobile
rindt meilleur temps aux essais du grand
prix de grande-bretagne à brands hatch
football l'avant centre de marseille
joseph jouera pour quatre ans à
valenciennes golf l'australien g a
remporté l'open de golf de
saint-jean-de-luz devant le français
garaïalde battu seulement 20 pour des
images maintenant rafraîchissante qui
nous vient des états unis et qui vont
très certainement inspiré bernard de
ronces rennes illustrateur sonore
cela se passe sur le plan d'eau de
galloway gardens et en géorgie aux états
unis il s'agit d'un championnat de ski
nautique a lieu tous les ans cette
époque vous avez un seau de l'américaine
liz allen qui est une des meilleurs
spécialistes du monde
si vous êtes actuellement en vacances il
nous fait du ski nautique vous pouvez
prendre une leçon ici pour améliorer
peut-être votre style voilà ce qu'il
faut faire si voulait sauter à 5 ans
tanner un tremplin où près de 2 mètres
de haut et vous allez voir quelques
instants ce qu'il ne faut pas faire
plus peur que de mal c'est dès qu'une
chute de schnyder encore un saut je vous
rappelle que le record du monde de saut
à ski nautique et de plus de 50 mètres
ces images sont d'ailleurs d'actualité
puisque aujourd'hui commence à cholet
dans le maine et loire les championnats
de france de ski helvétique ainsi michel
drucker france vérité avec cette page
magazine du journal nous ouvrons
quelques petits échos de vacances
quelques échos évidemment mais je
voulais commencer par vous entretenir
d'anigo qui nous vient des usa de nevada
les touristes et les voyageurs qu'il
veut savoir ce que l'on peut faire au
niveau de ce qu'il y à découvrir
reçoivent des lettres sur sur les vastes
espaces et casino les stations de sports
d'hiver et ce sont des notes ma foi très
convaincante
et pourtant ces lettres sont écrites par
trois prisonnières prisonnière de la
prison de carson city qui n'ont autre
chose à contempler vous vous en doutez
que les barreaux de leur fenêtre depuis
quatre mois elles ont répondu à plus de
cent mille lettres et l'une d'elles a
répondu eh bien cela fait deux ans que
je lui suis ce que je suis ici et cela
me fait maintenant une raison de me
lever le matin
il est si vous passez vos vacances en
france et si vous passez par saint malo
vous aurez à découvrir un musée fort
intéressant en effet ils sont quelques
centaines de cap hornier à travers le
monde qui ont réuni rassembler leurs
documents dans cette fameuse tour tour
de saint malo solidor louis doucet
la visite est pour nous c'est à manquer
à la gloire d'une des plus belles
épopées de l'humanité la fabuleuse
aventure des cap horniers c'est
aujourd'hui chose faite à saint malo la
tour solidor abrite leurs musées qui
raconte la vie de ces marins depuis que
des hollandais franchir pour la première
fois la pointe extrême de l'amérique du
sud
il s'appelait schouten et le maire par
une étrange coïncidence à des derniers
commandant à être passé à la voile par
le cap horn s'appelle lui aussi le maire
qu'est-ce que c'était le cas pas
vous savez on l'appelait le cap dire
très souvent fait le point développe
d'autant plus difficile à franchir au
temps des voiliers à tel point que même
les vapeurs n'est pas ce qui est
maintenant le cap horn le voici
par temps calme et ciel bleu photo
exceptionnelle car on sait qu'un navire
sur quatre n'est jamais revenu de cet
effrayant voyage au nom à cause de ce
cash cash perpétuel avec la mort le cap
horn est devenu quelque chose comme un
symbole une mystique et l'on regarde
aujourd'hui presque senti croire les
survivants de ce roman d'aventurés
qu'est ce que c'est cet incident
commandant
les fondateurs de l'amicale ont choisi
cela parce que c'était la plaine le
mangeur d'homme c'est l'albatros
innovant dans l'attitude c'est au sud de
40 m6
jetez votre compagnon du cap horn c'est
lui là oui mais bon j'ai peut-être le
cap en a t'il forger une race d'hommes
particulière acceptant tous les périls
avec humilité travaillant comme des
forçats s'amusant parfois comme des
enfants ramenant terre d'étranges
souvenirs pour légitimer leurs récits
une sirène me bresson mi-femme un musée
des rêves pour prolonger les rêves des
femmes cap en dur oui d'ailleurs il y en
a quand même une qui avait tendresse
pour le moment du mal à séparer les
vendant tous les deux la batte étape en
jeu par trois fois avec romain y en a
plusieurs qui sont mortes et dans leur
village et noéline qui a eu un fils qui
est né là-bas au cap en ouverture face
et comme il est pour vous or vivent dans
ces dominé depuis quatre ans maintenant
maintenant j'ai envie de leur mère j'ai
tellement d'amis parmi les bretons qui
je pari de faire accepter son fardeau mi
journée
elle boude aventure
une dépêche de dernière minute en
provenance du portugal qui nous donne
des nouvelles de l'ancien président
monsieur oliveira salazar la tension
artérielle du docteur salazar a
subitement baissé ce qui est considéré
éditons comme un symptôme grave dans
l'évolution de l'état de santé de
l'ancien président du conseil portugais
et aux dernières nouvelles le docteur
salazar serait dans un état celui comète
voilà france vérité maintenant la bourse
oui nous allons à la bourse de paris est
peut-être michel tardieu pouvons-nous
vous demander des nouvelles de la livre
sterling
je ne crois pas que ce soit le sujet qui
préoccupe le plus les boursiers
aujourd'hui encore que sur le marché de
l'or bien sûr on parle beaucoup des
mauvaise santé de la livre et de l'est
i on parle beaucoup de la dévaluation
probables ou possibles de la lire
italienne mais ça n'a pas de gros seins
de grosses influences vous verrez tout à
l'heure que le marché de l'or reste
calme sur le marché des valeurs
et bien c'est vraiment l'ambiance de
vacances on reste très très étroits
comme volumes de transactions et les
cours sont assez irrégulier pour les
valeurs françaises ou valence étrangères
les allemandes qui hier s'était
particulièrement distingué et bien
perdre leurs bénéfices de la veille
elles sont pour la plupart en repli
quant aux américaines elles sont
toujours très ferme et l'amélioration de
wall street qui est quand même la
préoccupation majeure des boursiers en
ce moment l'amélioration de wall street